trying to make it nine consecutive wins
trying to make it 11 straight wins
against the red sox and now a full count
to giancarlo stanton
got him looking couple to strike out
runners at first and second with one
gone for jd martinez
wow what a sequence there
again he's shown him everything in a
nine pitch plate appearance here's the
next 2-2 home to christian vasquez
finally got him
it took some doing
an error a walk but three strikeouts for
jordan montgomery first and second with
one god so here's her shelling now with
one gun and runners aboard
back up the middle smothered by arroyo
who will flip it to bogarts for one and
they double him off
red sox position perfectly to turn that
into a rather routine ending ending
double play the yankees runners at first
and second once again there's judge who
struck out looking in the first 2-2
on the ground another double play ball
and once again perez gets cleaned up
with a ground ball
full count to gleber torres
and a cold strike three
boy martin perez has been phenomenal to
start this night and there are two gone
here two balls and no strikes to
christian arroyo
oh a swinging a drive to left that ball
is crushed and gone three-run homer for
christian arroyo
well he's taking advantage of his chance
christian arroyo ron renicke said he's
done well
inside part of the plate and that is
usually what hitters do at fenway park
three-nothing boston when you see six
strikeouts all looking through four and
a third the umpire has played a role
period
that is a strike and it's a called
strike three for this seventh time how
about the movement on that ball chance
for martinez to drive in a run with just
a fly ball here runner at third with one
gone and steady swings and misses for
out number two
well you wouldn't know it was the same
hitter would you guy who signed with the
mets as an infielder
over 10 years ago vasquez gets him into
the gap in left center field
that'll score bogarts easily and
christian vasquez has his second base
hit of the night this one makes it 4-0
boston
martin perez back to work top half of
ending number six he has been brilliant
tonight he has scattered a couple of
hits
walked a batter hit another struck out
seven all of them looking
runners at first and second one gone in
both the second and third tonight but
double play ground balls got perez out
of jams
oh and le mayhew's jammed he pops it
into shallow right gonna be a tough play
and a fine over-the-shoulder grab by
michael chavis
oh no that was arroyo flying in from
second base
what a catch wow
player of the game so far
three run homer
and then and then the ability almost
like willie mays in the 54 series to
turn around and make the throw back in
judges had a rough night called out on
strikes in the first grounded into a
double play in the third
jammed again on the ground for bogarts
to royo for one on the first the double
play
the third turn behind martin perez
tonight flashy boston defense keeping
the yankees quiet again torres hicks and
herschela aboard two gone top half of
the seventh and the best opportunity the
yankees have had all night to get on the
scoreboard
into the corner and that's damage it'll
bounce up and over the wall a two-run
double
and the yankees are on the scoreboard in
the seventh clint frazier to tie the
ball game with the base hit he has
singled and been hit by a pitch tonight
frazier off the end of the bad little
dribbler for arroyo and it's capped at
two runs but the yankees do cut their
deficit in half on the bases loaded two
run double by gary sanchez so judge
aboard with one away now for giancarlo
stanton
folk out pitch
stanton rips it into the corner
a fair ball
judges being sent around to score
[Music]
no play at the plate and it's a one-run
ball game
one run game with the tying run in
scoring position
that
he said forget about the spin i'm going
to throw it 97 on the corner
and the yankees will be down to their
final out tonight
sanchez into left and gone to tie the
ball game
a two-run double in the seventh in a
game tying homer in the top of the ninth
luke
major league baseball's home run leader
has been conspicuously quiet tonight
floyd with a smash into left field
martinez has got it talkman's able to
score
and the yankees have broken out on top
their first lead of the night arroyo can
tie it by putting the ball in play
back up the middle of base hit we're
tied at five
well we keep getting new players of the
game every year
now we got another a candidate back in
the
back in the mix again two gone last to
the 11th winning run 90 feet away
vasquez sends a fly ball out to right
that will send this game into a 12th
inning well one more chance for le
mayhew 0 for four with a walk
into right field
[Music]
and it's a fair ball
hicks comes around to score
6'5 new york
it was just one too many chances for dj
le mayhew it's going to take a base hit
from michael chavis now the last chance
for boston he's jammed a roller for
torres
and the yankees have survived coming
back all the way from a four-nothing
deficit